ahoj, jmenuji se Olivia Lanes a vítej zpět v Quantum Computing v praxi. Toto je epizoda dvě – Quantum
circuits. Dnes v přednášce probereme několik témat, ale chci, abys odcházel/a s těmito třemi věcmi. Za prvé, co IBM
kvantové počítače vlastně jsou, abys měl/a alespoň hrubou představu o tom, co děláš, když odesíláš úlohu do jednoho z nich přes
cloud. Za druhé, co je Qiskit, co jsou Primitives a jak je můžeme použít k vytváření a spouštění Quantum circuits.
Také probereme na vysoké úrovni různé typy IBM Quantum procesorů, které jsou k dispozici, a co odlišuje jeden od druhého. A za třetí
a nakonec – typický workflow, který sledujeme k provádění experimentů ve velkém měřítku. To zahrnuje výběr nejlepších Primitives
pro tvůj případ použití, mapování problému na Quantum circuit a aplikaci potlačování a zmírňování chyb, které nám umožňují
vytěžit z těchto strojů maximum. Teď je tu hodně informací, ale vydržte se mnou,
protože brzy to všechno dáme dohromady v kontextu několika reálných příkladů. Nejprve si stručně promluvme o qubitech a skutečném Quantum
Hardware. Jako experimentalista ti mohu slíbit, že je to fascinující a opravdu pomáhá spojit tečky a
vizualizovat, co se vlastně děje, když jsou úlohy odeslány na kvantový počítač přes cloud. Procesory, které
budeme používat, jsou postaveny se supravodivými transmon qubity. Zde je to, jak vypadá malý IBM kvantový procesor.
Tyto malé čtverce jsou samotné qubity, takže na tomto čipu jsou celkem pět. Transmon
sám je kondenzátor a skládá se ze dvou kovových destiček zapojených paralelně s nelineárním induktorem nazvaným
Josephsonova spojka. Ale abys viděl/a Josephsonovu spojku, musíš přiblížit ještě více. Je vytvořena ze dvou
překrývajících se vrstev supravodivého kovu a tam, kde se oba kusy překrývají a dotýkají, je spojka. Josephsonova
spojka je prvek, který lze použít k vytvoření umělého atomu s více energetickými hladinami, a my izolujeme
spodní dvě energetické hladiny jako náš stav qubit. Klikaté linie zde představují mikrovlnné rezonátory –
v podstatě 2D přenosové linky spojené s qubit. Když naprogramujeme gate, v podstatě to odpovídá výběru
vysoce kalibrovaného mikrovlnného pulzu a specifická frekvence, amplituda, tvar a trvání těchto pulzů způsobují, že
qubit dělá konkrétní věci. Instrukce pro mikrovlnný pulz jdou z tvého počítače do cloudu a
jsou poté čteny a interpretovány pokojovou řídicí elektronikou, která tyto instrukce vezme a fyzicky
generuje pulzy. Říkáme jim mikrovlnné pulzy, protože všechny spadají do pásma mikrovlnných frekvencí,
které je přibližně 1 GHz. Poté, co pokojové řídicí krabice vytvoří pulzy, putují kabely
do dilučního chladiče a nakonec na náš kvantový čip. Signál vstupuje do rezonátorů přes
drátovou vazbu na těchto podložkách a poté teče dolů přenosovou linkou do našich qubitů. Vím, že to vše mohlo
být trochu technické a tyto detaily nejsou pro nás v dalším postupu klíčové, ale doufám, že nyní si
všichni alespoň dokážete představit fyzický systém, s nímž se chystáte interagovat. Kde tyto kvantové počítače
vlastně existují? IBM má desítky kvantových počítačů po celém světě a nedávno jsme upgradovali naši flotilu tak, aby
obsahovala pouze procesory s 100+ qubity, jak jsem zmínil/a v předchozí lekci. Některé z nich se nacházejí v IBM
Quantum datovém centru ve státě New York. Tyto systémy jsou nasazeny po celém cloudu pro použití všemi, a některé
z nich jsou vyhrazené on-premise systémy s veškerou elektronikou potřebnou k jejich fungování, která podporuje naše partnery
v IBM Quantum síti. Teď si promluvme o Qiskit, což je IBM open-source software development kit
navržený pro práci na kvantových počítačích. Od nynějška na toto budu odkazovat jako na Qiskit SDK. Existuje také Qiskit
ekosystém, což je kolekce softwaru, tutoriálů a funkcí, které staví na nebo rozšiřují základní funkcionality Qiskit, stejně jako Qiskit
runtime, což je Quantum Computing service a programovací model, který umožňuje uživatelům navrhovat a efektivně
spouštět jejich kvantové workloady pomocí Qiskit Primitives. A Primitive je v podstatě malý stavební blok, který
můžeš použít k navrhování větších circuits nebo úloh. Dva Primitives, které jsou pro nás nejdůležitější, budou
sampler a estimator, o kterých budeme podrobněji hovořit za chvíli. Pokud jsi ještě nestáhl/a a nenainstaloval/a
Qiskit SDK, lepší čas není. Qiskit 1.0 byl nedávno vydán a je výkonnější a
stabilnější než kdy dřív. Takže pro ty, kteří teprve začínají, přišli jste ve skvělý čas. Pro ty,
kteří již znáš Qiskit, budeš muset stáhnout a přeinstalovat nejnovější verzi. Doporučujeme používat
pip k instalaci Qiskit a Qiskit runtime a spouštět je přes Jupiter notebook ve webovém prohlížeči dle tvého výběru. Takže také budeš muset
nainstalovat Jupyter Notebook nebo JupyterLab, pokud jsi to ještě neudělal/a. Tyto nástroje jsou všechny zdarma a
můžeš je zprovoznit na svém lokálním počítači bez jakýchkoli nákladů. Nezapomeň přidat Qiskit s možností vizualizace
závislostí, aby fungoval s Jupiterem a umožnil ti vykreslovat věci. Také budeš muset nastavit virtuální python prostředí a existují
instrukce, jak to udělat, na Qiskit instalační stránce odkazované zde. Jakmile se budeš s Qiskit dobře seznámovat a jsi
připraven/a spouštět úlohy na reálných kvantových počítačích, budeš se muset zaregistrovat na quantum.com a vytvořit IBM Quantum
API token. Odkaz na toto je také zde. Podrobný průvodce, jak to provést, sleduj všechny
instrukce na naší dokumentační stránce, jak jsem zmínil/a, nebo se můžeš podívat na video instalace Coding with Qiskit zde.
Obojí je odkazováno v popisu. Teď jsme téměř připraveni začít mluvit o Quantum
circuits. Protože cílem tohoto kurzu je naučit tě, jak rozšiřovat úlohy na spuštění ve 100+
qubitovém měřítku, věřím, že nejkonstruktivnější způsob postupu je nejprve zvážit celkový workflow, který budeme sledovat. A nejsnazší způsob, jak
porozumět typickému Quantum Computing workflow, je prostřednictvím Qiskit patterns. Qiskit patterns jsou konceptuální framework umožňující uživatelům spouštět Quantum
workloady implementací určitých kroků s modulárními nástroji. To umožňuje provádění Quantum Computing úloh pomocí
výkonné heterogenní výpočetní infrastruktury. Tyto kroky lze provádět jako službu a mohou
zahrnovat Resource Management, který umožňuje bezproblémovou kompozici nových schopností, jak jsou vyvíjeny. Zde
jsou hlavní kroky, které zkušení uživatelé Qiskit pravděpodobně již znají. Prvním krokem je mapování. Tento krok
formalizuje, jak vezmeme obecný problém, o který máme zájem, a přijdeme na to, jak ho namapovat na kvantový počítač
ve formě circuit. Dále optimalizujeme – v tomto kroku používáme Qiskit transpiler k routingu a rozložení
circuit na skutečný fyzický Quantum Hardware. To zahrnuje překlad jednotlivých Quantum Gates do sekvencí
WEBVTT
operací prováděných na hardwaru, stejně jako optimalizaci rozložení těchto Gates. Dále budeme
spouštět. Qiskit runtime Primitives poskytují rozhraní k IBM Quantum Hardware, které umožňuje spuštění transpilovaného circuit.
Tento krok také zahrnuje použití technik potlačování a zmírňování chyb, které lze z velké části abstrahovat od uživatele. Nakonec post-processujeme.
V tomto kroku jsou data z kvantového procesoru zpracována a poskytují uživateli užitečné výsledky pro původní problém. V podstatě tento krok
zahrnuje jakoukoli další analýzu získaných dat. Teď jsme připraveni diskutovat o základech kvantových
programů – Quantum circuits. Doufejme, že Quantum circuits již znáš, ale pokud ne, možná bys chtěl/a nejprve se podívat na lekci
tři – Quantum circuits, která je součástí „Understanding Quantum Information and Computation" – odkaz níže. Zde
budeme jen poskytovat krátký opakující přehled. Quantum circuit je síť kvantových Gates a měření spojených
dráty, které reprezentují qubity. Quantum circuits lze číst jako noty zleva doprava, začínající v
čase nula zcela vlevo. Virtuální qubity – tedy qubity, které ještě nebyly přiřazeny k fyzickým qubitům
na procesoru – jsou seřazeny ve vzrůstajícím pořadí shora dolů. Jakmile nastavíme náš circuit, můžeme do něj přidávat
gates. Jednoduché qubitové gates, jako je tento Hadamard gate, ovlivňují pouze qubit, na jehož drátu je umístěn. Vícequbitové
gates, jako je CNOT, ovlivňují dva nebo více qubitů spojených tímto gate. V tomto příkladu se stav qubitu jedna mění
v závislosti na stavu qubitu nula. Po aplikaci všech gates můžeme provádět měření,
která způsobují zapsání výsledků do klasických registrů. Jednou zvláště důležitou charakteristikou
circuit je jeho hloubka. Hloubka Quantum circuit je minimální počet vrstev kvantových Gates prováděných
paralelně potřebných k dokončení výpočtu definovaného circuit. Jasně – Quantum Gates lze provádět
paralelně – jinými slovy ve stejnou chvíli – kdykoli nemají společné qubity. Ale pokud dva nebo více
gates působí na stejné qubity, nemůžeme je provádět paralelně. Jsme nuceni je provádět jeden po druhém, protože Quantum Gates potřebují čas k
implementaci. Hloubka circuit zhruba odpovídá množství času potřebnému pro kvantové počítače k provedení
circuit. Znalost hloubky circuit je tedy důležitá pro to, zda ji lze spustit na konkrétním zařízení. Také nám to řekne, zda má
dobrou šanci přinést přesný výsledek. Dále přejdeme k výběru Quantum procesoru. IBM
nedávno vydalo zcela novou flotilu procesorů, všechny s více než 100 qubity, a na quantum.com se můžeš přihlásit, abys viděl/a,
ke kterým procesorům máš přístup. Procesory jsou všechny pojmenovány podle ptáků z různých důvodů a různá loga
reprezentují různé typy procesorů. Například tyto représentují procesory Eagle a tato ikona je
Heron. Názvy konkrétních procesorů jsou také uvedeny nahoře – jsou všechny pojmenovány podle měst, ale to
nutně neznamená, že je procesor fyzicky umístěn v tom městě – to jsou jen názvy. Počet qubitů,
EPPG a CLOPS jsou také faktory, které jsou všechny uvedeny. Projdeme si každý z nich.
Qubity – to je poměrně samozřejmé. Qubity je jen celkový počet qubitů dostupných k použití na daném Quantum procesoru neboli
QPU. EPPG označuje chyby na vrstvový gate, který měří průměrnou chybu gate procesu ve vrstveném řetězci
100 qubitů. V podstatě chceš, aby bylo co nejmenší. CLOPS označuje circuit layer operations per second a
měří, kolik vrstev circuit Quantum volume, což je virtuální circuit, může QPU spustit za jednotku času.
Čím vyšší číslo, tím rychleji můžeme počítat. To je ekvivalent toho, co FLOPS znamená v klasickém computingu. Tyto
různé metriky mohou být více či méně důležité v závislosti na konkrétní aplikační oblasti, o které máš zájem. Dále si promluvme na vysoké úrovni
o mapování na Quantum circuits. Prvním krokem je krok mapování, který v podstatě odpovídá na otázku: jak
přeložím svůj problém do Quantum circuit, který lze spustit na Quantum Hardware? Není pochyb o tom,
že mapování je těžký problém a je aktivní oblastí výzkumu. Někdy jen schopnost vzít výpočetní
problém a vymyslet sekvenci kvantových Gates, která pomůže ho řešit, je nejtěžší část. Neexistuje žádná spolehlivá
metoda zaručující úspěch, ale existují doporučené pokyny a příklady problémů, které již víme, jak
mapovat. První pokyn je nechat klasické počítače dělat veškerou práci, které jsou samy lepší. Úlohy,
které jsou pro klasické počítače snadné, pravděpodobně nebudou benefitovat z kvantového počítače. Kvantové počítače jsou pro problémy, které jsou klasicky těžké.
Samozřejmě, pokud je to tvůj úplně první čas s Qiskit nebo kvantovým počítačem, netrap se nalezením výpočetně složitého problému. Rozděl ho
na menší problémy, které se naučíš řešit, než půjdeš rovnou na utility scale projekt. Dále přelož
výsledky svého problému, které chceš měřit nebo pochopit, do problému střední hodnoty nebo problému vzorkování.
Pro většinu typů problémů to v podstatě odpovídá výpočtu cost function. Cost function je
problémově specifická funkce, která definuje cíl problému jako něco k minimalizaci nebo maximalizaci, a lze ji
použít k zjištění, jak dobře si zkušební stav nebo řešení stojí vzhledem k tomuto cíli.
Tuto myšlenku lze aplikovat na různé aplikace v chemii, strojovém učení, financích, optimalizaci a tak dále.
Také mej na paměti, že hardware, který budeš používat, má specifickou topologii. Některé qubity nejsou propojeny
a některé jsou. A nakonec budeš muset namapovat svůj problém na circuit, který toto représentuje. IBM Quantum procesory
používají tzv. heavy hex topologii, která v podstatě odpovídá qubitovým připojením v hexagonální mřížce, do
níž se ponoříme více později v kurzu. Prozatím je nejdůležitější věcí, mít na paměti, že tato fáze vyžaduje
praxi. Musíš mít dobré porozumění nejen svému problému, ale také schopnostem kvantového hardwaru,
a projdeme si konkrétní příklad a případ použití později, abychom viděli, jak lze tyto nejlépe
vyvážit. Teď si promluvme o tom, jak optimalizovat circuit pro hardware, který jsme vybrali. Celkovým cílem
optimalizačního kroku je namapovat všechny virtuální qubity z našeho circuit na skutečné reálné qubity někde na
topologii procesoru. Jménem hry je snížit chyby co nejvíce. K tomu musíme nejprve
efektivně routovat a rozložit náš circuit. První věc, na kterou je třeba pamatovat, je, že ne všechny qubity jsou propojeny –
jak jsem již řekl/a, některé jsou od sebe na čipu daleko. Takže musíme snížit nebo eliminovat interakce na velké vzdálenosti
kdykoli je to možné. Můžeš aplikovat sekvenci swap gates mezi sousedními qubity, abys přesunul/a informace qubitů,
ale swap gates jsou nákladné a náchylné k chybám, takže mohou existovat lepší způsoby. Dále layout
WEBVTT
a routing jsou iterativní procesy a přiřazují virtuální qubit k tvému circuit na fyzický qubit na
hardwaru. Můžeš to udělat ručně, ale existují také nástroje v Qiskit, které mohou doporučit fyzické
rozložení qubitů na základě přibližných chybových sazeb. Dále můžeme skládat sekvence jednoho qubitového gates působících na stejný qubit
do jediného gate a někdy se také můžeme zbavit nepotřebných gates nebo kombinací gates. Například
některé kombinace gates lze zredukovat na jednodušší kombinace a někdy se kombinace gates dokonce
rovnají prostému identity operátoru, takže je lze jednoduše eliminovat. Toto lze provést automaticky pomocí
Qiskit transpileru nebo to lze provést ručně na základě gate po gate, pokud k tomu máš dobrý důvod a chceš
více kontroly. Jakmile jsme vylepšili rozložení circuit, routing a počty gates – buď ručně nebo pomocí Qiskit transpileru –
obvykle chceme vizualizovat náš circuit, abychom se ujistili, že časování všech gates dává smysl. V transpileru je argument, který lze přidat,
pro vizualizaci časové osy tvého circuit a ujistit se, že vše je v pořádku, jak bys očekával/a. Teď si promluvme o potlačování
chyb. Potlačování chyb se vztahuje na různé techniky, které transformují circuit během kompilace k minimalizaci chyb.
Je to odlišné od zmírňování chyb, které probíhá poté, co circuit byl již spuštěn, a k tomu se dostaneme za chvíli. Dvě nejběžnější formy
potlačování chyb, které využíváme, jsou dynamical decoupling a Pauli twirling. Zde bude trochu
technických detailů, ale na to se vždy můžeš vrátit později. Dynamical decoupling se používá k
efektivnímu zrušení části šumu ovlivňujícího qubit aplikací série gates, které dohromady odpovídají
identity operaci – jako XX sekvence – jejichž čistým efektem je přibližné zrušení šumových kanálů ovlivňujících
qubit. Pauli twirling je způsob vkládání náhodných gates pro zjednodušení průměrného šumu. Náhodnost pomáhá
zabránit efektům různých chyb v kumulaci tak rychle a také usnadňuje charakterizaci šumu.
Tato metoda také tvoří základ techniky zmírňování chyb a budeme o tom hovořit později.
Je tu opět hodně informací a neboj se, pokud se to všechno hned nevstřebá. Naštěstí mnoho z toho lze provést automaticky pomocí Qiskit
transpileru. Transpilace může být složitá, ale je to tak klíčový krok k dosažení utility ve velkém měřítku,
že vyžaduje hodně pokusů a omylů k zvládnutí a dosažení nejlepších výsledků. Teď se chci stručně
věnovat Qiskit transpileru a jeho schopnostem. Udělám to na velmi vysoké úrovni a podrobnosti a příklady
uvidíme později. Obecně je transpilace proces přepisování daného vstupního circuit tak, aby odpovídal
topologii a konkrétnímu kvantovému zařízení, a optimalizuje circuit pro spuštění a odolnost vůči šumu. Také
přepisuje daný circuit do základních gates daného konkrétního Quantum procesoru, který jsi vybral/a k použití. Qiskit má čtyři
vestavěné transpilační pipeline a pokud nejsi obeznámen/a s optimalizací Quantum circuit, rozhodně doporučuji použít jednu z těchto
vestavěných pipeline. Ve výchozím nastavení transpiler zahrnuje těchto šest kroků: inicializace,
layout, routing, překlad, optimalizace a plánování. Inicializace se vztahuje na
jakýkoli počáteční průchod, který je vyžadován, než začneme circuit vkládat do backend. Typicky to zahrnuje
rozbalení vlastních instrukcí a převod circuit do pouze jednoho a dvou qubitových gates. Fáze layout aplikuje
mapování rozložení virtuálních qubitů v circuit na fyzické qubity na backend. Routing běží po aplikaci layoutu
a vkládá gates, jako jsou swap gates, do původního circuit, aby byl kompatibilní s konektivitou backend.
Čtvrtou fází je překlad. V této fázi jsou gates v circuit přeloženy do základní sady target
backend. Dále je optimalizace. Tato fáze spouští hlavní optimalizační
smyčku opakovaně, dokud není splněna podmínka, jako je dosažení určité cílové hloubky. Máme čtyři různé optimalizační
úrovně, ze kterých si můžeme vybrat. Nakonec je plánování. Tato fáze slouží pro jakékoli hardware-aware plánování na vysoké
úrovni. Plánování si lze představit jako vkládání prodlev do circuit pro zohlednění veškerého nečinného času na qubitech
mezi prováděním instrukcí. Takže, jak jsem řekl/a, existují čtyři optimalizační úrovně od 0 do tří, kde
vyšší optimalizační úrovně zabírají více času a výpočetního úsilí, ale možná skončíš s lepším circuit.
Optimalizační úroveň nula je určena pro experimenty charakterizace zařízení a jako taková pouze mapuje vstupní circuit na
omezení cílového backend. Neprovádí žádnou optimalizaci. Optimalizační úroveň tři
věnuje nejvíce úsilí optimalizaci circuit. Nicméně, protože mnoho optimalizačních technik v
transpileru je založeno na heuristikách, větší výpočetní úsilí nevede vždy ke zlepšení
kvality výstupního circuit. Pokud tě to zajímá více, podívej se na stránky transpileru v dokumentaci Qiskit
odkazované níže. Teď jsme připraveni diskutovat o skutečném spouštění Quantum circuit.
Qiskit runtime Primitives poskytují rozhraní k IBM Quantum hardware a také abstrahují potlačování
a zmírňování chyb od uživatele. Sampler Primitive vrací kvazi-pravděpodobnostní distribuci nebo počty
représentující pravděpodobnost měření určitých bitových řetězců nul a jedniček. Estimator Primitive vrací střední hodnoty
pozorovatelných odpovídajících fyzickým veličinám. Trochu podrobněji – sampler spouští circuit
vícekrát na kvantovém zařízení, provádí měření při každém spuštění a sestavuje pravděpodobnostní
distribuci z obnovy těchto bitových řetězců. Čím více spuštění nebo shots provede, tím přesnější výsledky
budou, ale to vyžaduje více času a kvantových zdrojů potřebných ke konkrétnímu spuštění. Konkrétně vypočítává pravděpodobnost
získání každého možného stavu standardní báze měřením stavu připraveného circuit. Qiskit
estimator používá složitý algebraický proces k odhadování střední hodnoty na reálném Quantum zařízení
rozložením pozorovatelné do kombinace jiných pozorovatelných, které mají known eigenbáze, a spouštěním.
Pod kapotou Primitives jsou techniky nazývané zmírňování chyb. Zmírňování chyb je zastřešující termín pro toto vše a
v podstatě se vztahuje na techniky, které nám umožňují snižovat chyby circuit modelováním šumu zařízení v době
spuštění. Typicky to vede k overhead Quantum pre-processingu souvisejícímu s trénováním modelu a klasickému
post-processingu overhead k zmírnění chyb v surovém výsledku pomocí generovaného modelu. Výměnou za tento
overhead jsme však schopni dosáhnout mnohem přesnějších výsledků. Existuje více technik, které lze implementovat pro
WEBVTT
zmírňování chyb a probereme tři z nich podrobněji. Věz však, že jde o oblast
aktivního výzkumu, takže nové techniky budou pravděpodobně vynalezeny a starší budou i nadále vylepšovány. Úroveň
resilience zvyšuje náklady – jinými slovy čas potřebný ke spuštění tvé úlohy. Již jsme řekli, že při
resilience úrovni nula transpiler vlastně nic nedělá s tvým circuit. Ale od resilience úrovně jedna zavádí metodu nazvanou Twirled
Readout Error Extinction neboli T-REx. Twirled Readout Error Extinction používá Pauli twirling k
zmírňování šumu, o čemž jsme se již zmínili. Je to velmi obecná a efektivní technika, která
intuitivně dělá šum méně nepravidelným a snadněji zpracovatelným. Od resilience úrovně dvě
zavádíme zero noise extrapolation neboli ZNE. Jde o populární techniku, se kterou jsme nedávno měli hodně
úspěchů. Myšlenka za ZNE může být trochu překvapivá – přidáme vlastně další
šum k tomu, co tam již je. Ale co to umožňuje, je extrapolovat v opačném směru a
předpovědět, jak by výsledky vypadaly, kdyby byl šum nižší. Toto lze provést několika konkrétními způsoby. Například
můžeme prodloužit gates, aby byly delší a tedy náchylnější k chybám, nebo můžeme spustit více gates, které nakonec
vedou k identity operaci, takže circuit se funkčně nemění, ale záměrně vzorkujeme více
šumu. Musíš to ale dělat pro každý circuit a každou střední hodnotu, kterou chceš sledovat, takže
vidíš, jak to může být v potřebném čase velmi nákladné. Jeden konkrétní typ ZNE se nazývá
probabilistic error amplification – PEA. Jakmile jsme se naučili model šumu pro gate, PEA pracuje vzorkováním
chyb z tohoto modelu šumu a jejich záměrným vkládáním do circuit. Jak jsem zmínil/a, hodně nových
technik se i nadále vyvíjí a doufejme, že budou implementovány, jak je vidíme přicházet víc a víc. Existuje ještě jedna konečná forma
zmírňování chyb, o které chci hovořit – probabilistic error cancellation. Namísto toho, aby byla na třetí resilience
úrovni, je PEC speciální schopnost, kterou musíš ručně zapnout v Qiskit, protože výpočetní prostředky
pro ni nejsou příliš dobře škálovatelné ve srovnání s ostatními technikami zmírňování chyb, které jsme probrali. Začínáš
tím, že se dozvíš o šumu ovlivňujícím tvůj circuit spuštěním obvodů pro charakterizaci šumu
pro každou unikátní vrstvu dvou qubitových gates ve tvém circuit. Tyto výsledky ti umožňují popsat šum
pomocí Pauliho operátorů. Jakmile znáš tyto šumové členy, můžeš modifikovat své circuits tak,
aby efektivně měly opačné PEC zabudované, pro zrušení těchto šumových kanálů. V jistém smyslu tento proces je
podobný noise-cancelling sluchátkám. Nicméně tento způsob rušení šumu je velmi nákladný s časem pro spuštění,
který roste exponenciálně rychle s počtem gates, takže nemusí být nejlepší volbou pro velmi velký circuit. Dosáhli jsme
nyní konečné fáze – post-processingu. Pokud jsi odvedl/a dobrou práci a použil/a správné techniky
zmírňování chyb, můžeš vidět, jak se tvá konečná odpověď posune, jako na tomto obrázku. Nemitigovaná distribuce
zobrazená fialově je poměrně daleko od skutečné očekávané hodnoty zobrazené zde touto čárou. Nicméně jakmile použijeme naše
zmírňování chyb, dostaneme mitigovanou distribuci zobrazenou zde modrou, která má maximum mnohem blíže skutečné hodnotě. Teď
to vše přichází za cenu a zde vidíme, že rozptyl nebo šířka distribuce je zvýšena, což
obecně není to, co chceš. Ale vše přichází za cenu. Naštěstí to můžeme zohlednit spuštěním více
shots, což způsobí zmenšení distribuce zpět na přijatelnou úroveň nejistoty. Tak to je přibližně vše pro tuto
lekci. Příště vezmeme všechny tyto kroky, dáme je dohromady a propracujeme se oblastí a příkladem
skutečného aplikačního zájmu. Je tu pár věcí, které doporučuji mezitím udělat. Pokud jsi ještě nestáhl/a,
ujisti se, že si stáhneš a nainstalujceš Qiskit 1.0. Můžeš se také podívat na přidruženou lekci pro tuto kapitolu a
předchozí díl na IBM Quantum learning platformě. A nakonec, pokud máš zájem ponořit se více do
učení o technikách zmírňování chyb, podívej se na jeden z četných zdrojů, které jsem odkazoval/a níže. Do té doby se uvidíme příště.
[Hudba]